E
DONE TO THIS COUNTRY?
IS.
>> I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD OF MY
SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY.
WILL: COLORADO CONGRESSMAN KEN
BUCK JOINS US THIS MORNING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT MOMENT.
TREASON.
YOU WENT DIRECTLY AT MAYORKAS
AND REPEATED SOMETHING YOU SAID
YOU'RE HEARING FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
I'M CURIOUS, IS THAT A SPECIFIC
TERM IN YOUR MIND?
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT IS
NARROWLY TAILORED IN YOUR
INDICTMENT OF WHAT MAYORKAS HAS
DONE IN HIS JOB?
>> MY CONSTITUENTS UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN AN NFLING COACH
DOESN'T WIN A GAME FOR 13
SEASONS, 5 SEASONS, 3 SEASONS,
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOB.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS SHOULD LOSE
HIS JOB.
WHAT HE'S DONE AT THE BORDER IS
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL FAILURE.
HE HAS DISMANTLED THE EFFECTIVE
POLICIES FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND THE RESULT IS THAT WE HAVE
CHAOS AT THE BORDER.
WE HAVE RECORD NUMBERS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY, WE HAVE THOUSANDS
OF POUNDS OF FENTANYL COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY, WE HAVE
RECORD NUMBERS OF AMERICANS
DYING FROM FENTANYL OVERDOSE.
NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH
BETWEEN AGES 18-45, FENTANYL
OVERDOSE.
THAT'S DISGRACEFUL.
AND THIS SECRETARY THE ACTS AS
IF HE HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL ON THE
BORDER.
WHEN I ASKED HIM -- WHAT I ASKED
HIM TO DO WAS TO EXPLAIN TO MY
CONSTITUENTS WHY HE IS NOT
ACTING INTENTIONALLY WHEN HE IS
OPENING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WILL: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO, I
WANT TO ACTUALLY COME BACK TO
YOUR ANALOGY IN ONE MOMENT, BUT
LET'S FOLLOW UP ON THIS LINE OF
QUESTIONING ABOUT THE
IMPEACHMENT -- OR TREASON AND
THEN WHAT IT COULD MEAN IN TERMS
OF THE CONCEPT OF IMPEACHMENT
BROUGHT UP.
I'VE HONESTLY NEVER HOW ABOUT
THIS WHEN IT COMES TO CABINET
MEMBERS.
HOW DOES THAT PROCESS WORK?
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DONE IN REMOVING, YOU KNOW, AN
OFFICER UNDER THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH?
>> IT CAN BE.
A OFFICER CAN BE IMPEACHED BY
CONGRESS.
OBVIOUSLY, THE HOUSE IMPEACHES
EXPECT SENATE CONVICTS. -- AND
THE SENATE CONVICT WITHS.
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN
REMEMBER A MORE DESERVING
CANDIDATE FOR IMPEACHMENT THAN
SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
WHAT HE HAS DONE IS INTENTIONAL.
YOU KNOW, HE HAS THESE PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS PAYING USING
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO PAY THAT
ACTUALLY RECRUIT, ALLEGEDLY,
RECRUIT AND TRAIN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY AND SAY THE RIGHT
THINGS.
WILL: RIGHT.
>> IF THAT'S HAPPENING ALONG
WITH OPENING OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, ALONG WITH HIS STATEMENT
THAT HE BELIEVES WE SHOULD HAVE
AMNESTY FOR PEOPLE WHO COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, THEN I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT HE HAS DONE IS
CERTAINLY DESERVING OF FURTHER
SCRUTINY.
WILL: YEAH.
AND, CONGRESSMAN, I'M CORRECTING
YOU ON SPECIFICITY WHEN WITH IT
COMES TO THIS TERM BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, ULTIMATELY,
IS ACCOUNTABILITY.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY DOUBT
THAT THE OATH OF OFFICE HAS BEEN
ABDICATED, AND IT HAS BEEN DONE
SO INTENTIONALLY.
SO AT THE END OF OUR
CONVERSATION, LET'S PUSH FOR
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY THAT I'M
KIND OF NARROWLY TAILORING YOU
INTO.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOUR
ANALOGY.
WHEN A FOOTBALL COACH LOSES
GAMES, HE GETS FIRED, THE HEAD
COACH, AS YOU MENTIONED, IS
MAYORKAS THE HEAD FOOTBALL COACH
OR SIMPLY THE OFFENSIVE
COORDINATOR OR THE QUARTERBACK
COACH IMPLEMENTING A POLICY
COMING DOWN FROM THE HEAD COACH
THAT WE WOULD ASSUME IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S CLEARLY
ACTING AT THE DIRECTION AND AT
THE BEHEST OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT HE HAS TO ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WHAT HE'S DONE SPECIFICALLY,
PRESIDENT BIDEN ASKED HIM TO
LOOK AT THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY.
HE LEFT IT UP TO SECRETARY
MAYORKAS TO DECIDE TO REMOVE
THAT POLICY.
SO SECRETARY MAYORKAS WAS GIVEN
CERTAIN DISCRETION AND EXERCISED
THAT DISCRETION IN A WAY THAT IS
HARMFUL TO THE UNITED STATES
WITH.. -- SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE ALSO?
ABSOLUTELY.
WILL: ABSOLUTELY.
I GUESS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BEGINNING OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
WHERE THIS GOES.
CONGRESSMAN KEN BUCK, THANK YOU
FOR SHARING WITH US YOUR
INTENTIONS, W